this is brilliant this is the greatest
this is nothing's more hollywood than
this
saw's done the franchise is done until
we bring it back and call it something
other than the name of the franchise but
there's no marketing for a movie called
spiral so for marketing sake we're going
to squeeze the name saw in
at the end when we call it spiral from
the book of songs just
nothing's ever dead
[Music]
spiral or spiral from the book of saw
whatever it's called
i don't quite know what i'm going to
title this yet so spiral isn't a new saw
movie it's a saw copycat movie so it's
not really a soft sequel it's a sop
spinoff it's a saw sequel in the way
that us marshalls
was a fugitive sequel like
chronologically it's a sequel but
spin-off that kind of sequel point is
chris rock plays a cop in this movie
he's a good cop he's an honest cop and
he gets a new partner in their work in
this case this case it looks very
familiar to the old jigsaw killings
looks like we got
a copycat on our hands folks so chris
rock and his new partner
they're chasing the leads and chasing
the bodies
you know it's saw that's what we come
for but but it's not all this movie has
to it tries to do more that was a very
jumpy series of thoughts i apologize not
on my a game today
but i'll bring you this review all right
what i like in this movie out the gate
we meet chris rock's character and
right away i'm like i like this chris
rock energies bringing to the saw world
his monologue about forrest gump is is
damn near legendary and then after that
great introduction
that energy it kind of goes away like
not fully goes away i just think he gets
buried under the shrapnel that is the
mess of this movie more on that in a
second i don't want to jump around too
much still talking about what i like
i also like the traps i mean there
aren't a lot of traps in here i can
remember three of them but the traps
that we get were actually pretty
imaginative
imaginative traps there is a way out of
the trap whether or not they're going to
take the way out that's the question
very good
jigsaw-esque trap puzzles that do the
late john cramer justice and the reason
you're not inundated with a lot of traps
in this movie is because this movie
didn't want to be
a gore fest i mean the traps are gory
absolutely it's pretty brutal and bloody
but you can tell this movie wants to be
more it's going for something deeper
this movie wants to be
a compelling investigative film and
that's where this movie feels messy it's
where spiral feels like it has a case of
identity crisis it wants to be a song
movie but doesn't fully commit to being
a saw movie because it wants to be taken
seriously so it kinda wants to be like
a movie like seven but it doesn't fully
commit to that because well
we have to make it like a saw movie so
what you get is this weird hodgepodge
mess that really doesn't
feel like either doesn't excel at being
either it doesn't really find its own
identity everything cool in this movie
and this movie did have some interesting
stuff
but it's all stuff you hear about the
traps though entertaining you've seen
traps in these movies before but there's
a really compelling
backstory about chris rock some tension
between him and some cops because cops
don't like him and
some cops can't be trusted i'm like that
sounds amazingly interesting
i feel like that's the more interesting
movie bummer we kind of see it in really
quick snippet flashbacks
i feel like we should have spent more
time there i feel like this movie should
have been longer or was longer but had
things cut out
so it just feels kind of jumpy like this
movie's a series of location changes
where they're just like driving to one
place driving to another and you're just
watching the jigsaw stuff
happen in between there's no interesting
investigation in this movie there's no
actual chasing the trail of a killer
this movie intensely lacks a sense of
direction outside of hey
bad guy just there's another body and
obviously it's a trap thing
so i guess we better go there it's just
reacting to people who die
but again no actual pursuit no actual
you never feel like they're getting
closer to finding this person
but you know you know because this movie
it does a thing and i feel like i watch
a lot of movies
you know that so there's a part of me
that wants to assume this is a case of
me watching a lot of movies so i see a
lot of these tricks
and there was something that happened in
here where i was like well my list of
suspects just went down to one because
of how you executed this one
thing where else was i supposed to go
with that information keeping it vague
just in case but it was really sloppy
this is a case where i
appreciate what this movie was trying to
do but that's not enough to keep it
afloat i'm interested in seeing more in
this world wow
i'm saying the same things i said about
mortal kombat i guess we've seen this a
lot lately interested in seeing more of
this world for a sequel as long as they
can get better writers and focus it up
this movie isn't quite the
groundbreaking saw movie it wants to be
it doesn't quite elevate the content at
all all i can say is the movie happened
a movie with identity crisis that wasn't
quite saw wasn't quite investigative
manhunt movie wanted to be both
really was neither and i'm not gonna
remember it in t minus one day
yep already forgot alright so spiral
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]